you
most of my work is in 19th century
French history and both the veil book
and paketa are on 20th and 21st century
and I had done work on on feminist
demands for voting rights women get the
vote in France in 1944 I had done all
kinds of work on on that and then I
began to read about this movement for
Perry the movement porta potty and that
was devised by a group of French
feminists who many of whom were involved
in politics and who felt that they were
just hitting a brick wall or a glass
ceiling or whatever that there was just
so much toleration by the vast majority
of men who were in politics for women
coming in and one of the things they
pointed out was that since women had
gotten the vote in 1944 until they
started their movement in 1990 no more
than five and at most six percent of the
French parliament had had went were
women and this they seemed to them this
put France on a par with some of the
most on advanced countries of Europe and
indeed of the world and this was brought
up over and over again as a way of
thinking about what to do at first they
proposed quotas and quotas were struck
down by the French Constitutional Court
as unconstitutional and then they
proposed what they call Pat ETA and this
was where the thing we talked about
before about French universalism was a
sort of wonderful turn on French
universalism French universalism the
unit of universalism is the abstract
individual who has no characteristics no
social characteristics no religion no
raise no ethnicity nothing except
historically sex the reason women
weren't given the vote initially when
men got to vote which was in first they
had to vote in the French Revolution for
a while but in 1848 you have Universal
man who'd suffered women didn't get the
vote because they were thought to be
domestic dependent
the sex they were outside of the
political realm and so the the people
who supported patty ta argued that sex
was the one thing that couldn't be
abstracted for the purposes of the
abstract individual and if that was the
case then why not say that the abstract
individual came in two sexes male and
female but that all that that sexual
difference meant was anatomy it was
anatomical difference it had nothing to
do with social cultural political
behavior capabilities capacities those
were all culturally attributed and so
they began to campaign for fifty percent
representation for women and what they
argued was that there should be a law
that said the fifty percent of the
Parliament had to be all the fifty
percent of seats in the National
Assembly had to be for women and so on
in all political offices which didn't
fly terribly well although that was the
original plan so this movement developed
and they were they were ingenious in the
kinds of political things they did the
demonstrations they would have the signs
they would the posters they would hold
up all sorts of puns in French on the
National Assembly being you know all
male and I can't really reproduce them
in this but in any case there they moved
along and as different governments came
into they created coalition's also
across party lines this was one of the
really ingenious things with women who
were leaders in very different political
parties they also created a kind of
grassroots movement by bringing together
the heads of all the sort of voluntary
ascertain the association of graduates
women graduates of technical schools
women lawyers you know the kind of
professional associations and farmers
wives and whatever grassroots
associations the leadership of that came
together and supported signed the
petition also in favor of packing tape
and they created this sort of
groundswell of public opinion such that
at one point something like I don't
remember the numbers now but something
like 70 or more than
seventy percent of the population
surveyed both male and female thought
that there should be greater equality in
politics and they could imagine a woman
president of France even this was long
before Sagan nyo and you know her
attempt to become president so then the
Socialists came into power I think in
1997 and there seemed a real possibility
for getting this law passed because Joe
spam was inclined to do more egalitarian
sorts of things in this seemed like a
good thing to do and then the original
movement which was saying on the one
hand there have to be we have to take
sex into account in political
representation but on the other hand
saying that sex was irrelevant for the
capabilities and the characteristics and
the ideologies and the outlooks of women
and men that they were that the
differences were were not deeply rooted
or biological then in nineteen ninety
well in in the in the 90s but in 1998-99
it came to a head this coincided with
the push for domestic partnership
legislation in France and the domestic
partnership legislation unleashed a
campaign that could only be called
homophobic although some of its
representatives denied that they were
homophobic of the most extraordinary
sort in which everybody was okay with
the idea that they could be a contract a
domestic partnership contract but not
with the idea that gay couples could
have families that gay couples could
adopt or could have access to
reproductive technologies of all kinds
in vitro fertilization and stuff like
that and the law that passed did not
permit adoption or the recognition of a
homo parental family
the debate that unfolded around that was
one which reintroduced the notion of
sexual difference as a fundamental
distinction that had to be maintained
maybe it wasn't biological but it was
cultural people said things like
children have a right to know that they
are born of a man and a woman this in
the age of reproductive technology when
you know some children are produced in
in Petri dishes and you know whatever
that children would become psychotic if
they were raised by same-sex parents and
so on and so on and there was a book
published actually at the time called la
poltica sex the politics of sex by the
wife of Joseph L sylvian Augustine skia
philosopher of sorts and she argued in
favor of parity and against homosexual
parenting by saying that couples that
the sort of normal couple had to be a
man and a woman because it was
complementarity that had to be come into
play and similarly she said in politics
that complementarity has to be there so
no single sex legislators no single sex
families and that became the kind of
dominant discourse of the moment and
when the law passed the law on PA people
kept saying I agree or many of the
legislators who voted for it finally
said yes i agree with silvia makosinski
that there has to be complementarity
that women represent a different
sensibility a different set of concerns
a different head instead of interest and
we need to have those in the parliament
as well so on the one hand the law
passed but the underlying premises of it
had changed in the course of the history
of the movement for patty tay from one
in which the goal was to eliminate the
notion that there were
fundamental differences between men and
women and to one in which the
fundamental differences were what indeed
had to be represented
I think you know what what packingtown
now is it's a requirement that all the
ballots rather than that the legislature
has to be half and half that the ballots
that on most ballots and not all ballots
there has to be women have to be half
the candidates I'm not sure that would
work here I think it would be dismissed
as another form of quota as a secret
form of quota creeping in but I do think
that that the best sorts of situations
are one in which sexual difference
doesn't matter anymore and those happen
the more women because they are the ones
who are usually excluded the more women
you have in the group just as the more
african-americans you have in a group
the more the more of others become part
of what you get used to you stop
thinking about the differences of sex or
the differences of race you just deal
with them as people and you disagree
with their ideas you you say no I don't
you know I don't like that idea rather
than reacting to them as women or men or
black or white or or whatever I mean I
think those are in my experience of
having at the beginning of my career
being the one woman on the in the
department of history at the University
I first taught at to being part of a
group when I was at Brown University
under a court order Brown increased
dramatically increase the numbers of
women who were on its faculty after a
while you know nobody can say well all
women are like her or she's the
embodiment of what I hate about women
because the variety is is large enough
so that it becomes a kind of irrelevant
consideration or if not irrelevant
because it's never completely irrelevant
a minor consideration in the
institutional dealings and the practical
matters and the kinds of politics of
sorts of decisions that you have to make
so I think the more mixing you have the
more democratic and in fact the more
egalitarian things become
again it's never perfect I mean I think
they're always going to be deep
psychological issues about who's male
who's female men women is that but those
become less and less significant in
situations in which you have a fairly
large representation of the varieties of
groups that are that are possible